uh lily singh was renewed thank god
at least we got some good news and she
has a video talking about it this is
good news by the way
unironically for us let's check it out
oh my god
yo what's going on season two
by the way how old is she
old enough
way too excited for somebody getting a
season two like
right like shouldn't that be there have
been plenty of guys that are like oh
great season two
excellent very excited to announce
season two she's acting like somebody
who
really did not think season two might
have been coming right she's
very excited
oh my god i have so many thought this is
gonna be a very disorganized vlog where
i have many thoughts and i'm just like
if you haven't already heard a little
late with lily singh is getting a season
two you should have heard because
literally i've been posting it on my
instagram my twitter my youtube
[ __ ]
she's got a breath and every sounds like
lance the rapper and this fake
excitement is [ __ ] because she knew
like
two weeks ago okay i really
really do value time where i can just
talk to you directly into the camera
no one else is here like there's no
execs there's no teams just
i valued it so much that i left doing
this to go to a late night show with a
bunch of nbc
executives watching my every move and i
thought i would
talk to you honestly and genuinely about
my late night show no bs the top line
i did season one we wrapped it in
december of last year and i just got
renewed for a season two that is gonna
be shot i don't know when quarantine
don't pretend like we now listen don't
pretend like your
shooting schedule wasn't a mishmash
train wreck like [ __ ] apocalypse now
was
like seriously you have doomed
production schedules because people have
to
edit in and and manufacture crowd shots
and yeah like there's so much that goes
into creating a lily sing
god it really makes me again i was
watching this weekend one of my
favorites
i was watching some old letterman stuff
that guy just
came out banged out a show and left
was this came out banged out a show
everything you heard on that show where
people reacting to bill murray or
you know what i mean like it was always
just people talking and having a good
time bing bang boom
paul shaffer play us out let's get the
[ __ ] out of here and it's
done it was whipped up thrown into a
tape and delivered a [ __ ] um
30 rock that day and it was on the air
that night it was
boom done easy that's why you don't know
stop
it oh that makes me mad she's pretending
like you know corona really [ __ ] us up
guys
you have how many episodes in the can
that never saw the light of day
she should be coronavirus network's
dream right now because you're like whoa
hey at least we got all this lily singh
archive footage but
they're not even releasing it lily
that's how bad you suck
overall thoughts and feelings are i am
so excited i am beyond
honored actually no i'm excited i'm also
very nervous i'd be lying if i was like
oh i'm just
happy no i'm freaking nervous and i feel
like puking all over again as if this is
season one although as if i've never
done this
because like mike said earlier you never
planned on getting a season two you
never thought
you knew in your heart of hearts that
you were bad
you knew that this wasn't looking good
so you're excited you're nervous because
you're like jesus christ they fell for
it
before this is the first i'm gonna puke
season one let me break it down for you
we shot
she really is she reminds me of the
sales person on the showroom the floor
that like literally they go all right
yeah we'll take it and they go
really oh ow okay and then they have to
go run and get the sales manager and all
like i've never filled an invoice out
how do i do this how do i do this
episodes in three months and if you're
thinking
that's a lot you're right it is unlikely
we'd have to answer a question in the
chat sean o'brien has a valid question
so why haven't they canceled her sean
have you ever tried
firing a bisexual woman of color hiring
them is easy
that's easy you get the little pat on
the back hey look at how diverse we are
you ever tried getting rid of one in the
middle of the sjw age
imagine if they tried to fire her right
now it would be of everything else
imagine all the bad press they get
imagine how her management team and
everybody would start
slipping things to the press about oh
they never wanted her to work out
they actually said that this was just
they just did this to placate the
internet audience and they were going to
get rid of lily
they were always going to get rid of
lily and replace her with a white man
trust me that's why she's not fired
she's not fired because she was so
[ __ ] good she's hot she's still there
because
it is impossible to fire women it go
not even just in television dude go to
any job
there are women at every job site
getting away with the [ __ ] that guys
would
never ever get away with ever a million
years
dude just don't you can fire them but
they
they fire more grievances they file more
unemployment claims they go to the eeoc
they go
like they go everywhere every time
they've ever lost a job they [ __ ] and
moan they go on facebook they go
they have all their friends write bad
reviews for the play trust me you go
with any kind of
when when your identity is sjw i'm
bisexual woman
and that's all you yell about you're
going to be a problem trying to get rid
of yeah
they would look bad in the press because
of all the puff pieces that
other sites have written about her uh
nbc needs
and i like this is that this is their
token they every
no but for real they have a token i mean
think about it who are the other late
night show host on nbc
who are they white dudes that's who they
are
so they need a token they need something
to go hey it's not just white men over
here ladies
and and it's going to be one of those
they'll start writing articles about
like
uh you know uh uh you know wendy
williams network uh
you know they they they gave her some
time to succeed so what's the problem at
nbc yeah and all these little think
pieces about
why does it nbc has a real white man
problem
nbc get out of here all these little box
pieces it's going right now and firing
executives for covering up for harvey
weinstein that's in the news
no it's going on right now that's a lot
you're right
it is unlike any other late night host
who they usually shoot year-round
because of budget and scheduling and
just other things i had going on in the
year we shot 96 episodes
in three months because of budget and
schedule how many other things
how many aired i don't know not all 96.
did we get 96 episodes i don't really
sing
show i don't think so and let me just
candidly tell you what that was like
very hard now that you know that i'm
gonna tell you everything i loved about
season one
my team was amazing i would have gone
insane if it wasn't for my writers my
producers my av
my av i own the audio visual every
person
that was part of season one i am sane
because of you truly
including nbc i'll be real with y'all
when i got the show a part of me was
like are they gonna let me be me i'm
pretty weird
but nbc has never made me alter who i am
i can truthfully look at you and they
should
they should be they honestly i don't
often push for consultants
that's a show that needs consultants am
i wrong this show
needs well it needs to be canceled
but yes somebody should be telling her
what to do
every step of the way you shot 96
episodes in three months
because they weren't sure of you and
they wanted to be able to air the stuff
that they wanted because they didn't
have faith in you like they did with all
the other late-night hosts
and i will say this too that she's not
even a student of her craft
which really bothered that bothers me
about any person quite frankly like
you know i mean if you're a rapper and
you can't tell me who your favorite 80s
and 90s rappers are i don't respect you
if you're a comedian and you can't tell
me what old school
you know smoking on television era
comedians that you like i don't respect
you
this woman has never sat down and really
watched old carson
old letterman that's not her [ __ ] she
doesn't enjoy that stuff she enjoys
you know james charles videos and
jeffree star makeup [ __ ] you know what i
mean like that's the kind of [ __ ] this
broad
and her crowd are into she's never sat
down and just studied letterman
and go like what is he what does johnny
do during these interviews that i i
lack what does jay leno do despite
all his flaws but what does jay leno do
during a monologue or during an
interview that
is good and what does he do that's bad
why don't i
why don't i study that and take notes
why don't i read old newspaper articles
where they would compare these guys in
newspaper articles and the tv critics
would say
well you know letterman does a far
better interview he's got far better
interview skills but jay leno has a
stronger monologue and then you go
wow that was the consensus let me see
what his his monologues like and what
his interviews
she doesn't do any of that she doesn't
care what about if she just does like
black voice instead
and like freestyle dances he has no
desire
nighttime television changed to suit her
then change to suit the nighttime
television demographic right like is
that
unfair no let's play a little bit more
because we have to get out of here soon
practices
about shoot schedules like literally
amateur it was a really great experience
and i learned so much and i'm so
incredibly proud
of what we were able to do considering a
lot of the challenges associated with
the show but now i'm going to just be
real with you and tell you the things
that i think i can improve on one of
them
this is what i wanted to get to things i
pride myself in
is my self-awareness i think i'm pretty
good at being self-aware
no you're not lily you are very terrible
at being self-aware
if you were self-aware you would have
realized the entire internet was making
fun of you
for saying you were a bisexual woman of
color every single episode
and instead of going you know what maybe
i say that too much you did a monologue
on why you were right to do it
and so i can truthfully sit here and
tell you that there were some i'm
literally perfect it's not me
it's everyone else that it's me show
where i was like oh this is amazing i
love this
and there were other episodes where i
was like this ain't it
95 of them i am well aware
the schedule didn't always allow me to
have a monologue that i was 100
about imagine any [ __ ] late-night
person making a video full of excuses in
their announcement right
could you imagine could you imagine
jimmy fallon going hey guys uh
they're giving me a tenth season i'm
gonna be hosting a tonight show again
i'm very excited
and uh look there were some things this
year that really we could have fixed
that we could have done better right
could you imagine nobody's ever done
that they just come out you go
excited second year hey it's gonna be
even better than the first one
and we hope to be around for many years
to come thank you so much no questions
i would feel a little about it but the
show had to go on and yeah i'm well
aware that in some episodes i look
hella uncomfortable and you know what
that's probably because i am because
she's dressed like
season one of doing something brand new
and season one lily reminded me a lot
like first
youtube video lily you know everything
takes time it takes practice
and the reason i communicate this is
really just to say
i'm proud of season one but i know
there's a lot to improve on
and so when you give me feedback like
why doesn't she have this guest on the
show why isn't she doing this
it's not for lack of trying it's just
i'm trying to figure it out
so maybe they should hire somebody who
has a pedigree in television
to take on a role like a late night talk
show just a thought
yeah because if you think about all the
other late night show hosts they did
something before they became late night
talk show host
that would make them i don't know
qualified for it you know
david letterman had more failed pilots
than saudi arabia
yeah and he's [ __ ] you know what i
mean he had a morning show that sucked
he had an afternoon show that saw he had
a bunch of [ __ ] that sucked but he was
so good and he was so seasoned that nbc
went
we're going to pay you to stay we don't
know what we want to do with you yet
and then they made up the second late
night show slot for him because it was
like tom snyder or some [ __ ]
so maybe you're just not like again
there was no even back then he wasn't
going well we didn't have the right
stair and it was this and
i'm still learning he just like he'll
typically the first to tell you and go
yeah we did a show during the day and uh
you know people didn't like it
i had to go back to the drawing board
and figure out something people did like
but
it was never of like a thing where it
was like guys i'm still figuring this
out
like you don't say that right they're
supposed to be bringing in
seasoned professionals for television
many times i've been tempted to respond
to comments like why isn't this person
on your show and i'm like oh it's
because of their schedule
it's because they have a pr team that
does this this this why aren't you
playing this game on your show oh cause
legally we can't do that why aren't you
doing more sketches because when i shoot
one for my youtube channel it's this
much money when you shoot it for the
show it's this much money
then okay hold on whoa hold on a second
wow
hold on wow
okay all right then why
do your youtube sketch sketches look
like the
same exact quality as your high budget
nbc sketches
because if that's the case explain that
to me because
we've seen her youtube sketches we've
seen her nbc sketches do you see any
discernible
difference in quality between the two no
no right no there's none so that makes
no sense
no they're the same there are so many
things i have learned and i feel like
going into season two what i'm really
excited about
is taking all that knowledge all the
times i've made mistakes and stumbled
and was confused
now i know all that stuff i still have a
lot to learn but i know some stuff now
and i can so you just you get a tv show
and you get to wing it just get a tv
show and [ __ ] it
but [ __ ] brendan chubb over here
let's just give her a tv show and
hopefully she'll learn
but that's what i mean this is
unacceptable television is
a [ __ ] professional format say
whatever you want i know it sucks now
whatever we can all have that arguments
about all the shows
even a shitty show even criminal [ __ ]
minds
requires people to be hired for that
project
that are at least proficient in what
they do whether you're a cameraman
whether you're an editor whether you're
an actor now i get it joe montagna and
the gang aren't the [ __ ] top-notch
uh uh [ __ ] they're not gonna be winning
oscars anytime soon but
they're all proficient at what they do
this woman is basically saying yeah they
gave me a late night show i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing i'm winging it
could you imagine seeing that in any
other job dude you'd be fired
no no i bullshitted my way into this job
i don't know how a nuclear reactor works
explain it to me what is it so i'd wait
so i push this if this thing
turns red then i gotta call somebody uh
what do what do i do
yeah she's like the homer simpson of the
[ __ ] late night show host except
homer simpson's likable yeah
unbelievable man yeah homer simpson is
gonna die surrounded by loved ones
those [ __ ] grandkids i can step into
season two just
that much better so yes i am very proud
of season one i'm super excited for
season two to improve even more to break
the format even more to learn how to be
more comfortable
lily if i had to explain if i just
[ __ ] the woman
okay gross i know right gross
if i just [ __ ] some woman right and i
had to spend
four minutes and 55 seconds making
excuses for why she didn't come
and then i have the balls at the end of
that little [ __ ]
the end of that little [ __ ] speech go
i'm still really proud of the
[ __ ] you got that's what she's doing
here
if i sat there for three minutes and
went yo look i've never had sex before
it's all new to me honor i was very
confused i've never seen a vagina that
kind of scared me
freaked me out a little bit but we got
through it and hey you know what
i'm pretty proud of it right you'd be
left out of the [ __ ] room
yeah but what if you were like yo dawg
i'm gonna [ __ ] you right now
i don't think that would help you don't
think so no just trying
trying to through this awful she's so
awful